you are quite the matchmaker you wrote
the aladdin sketch for pete davidson
for pete davidson and kim kardashian and
you wrote in a kiss
look at all the trouble you started yeah
first of all now pete is ensconced in
this kardashian lifestyle did he ever
come to you and say thank you for
writing this i got to make out with this
chick and now i'm with her i mean i hope
there was a thank you abs absolutely not
but
absolutely he hasn't mentioned it in
fact this is the first time hearing that
they're dating is it serious
that's two kids
did pete come to you or um the other
three people who are
leaving bryant and kyle mooney yeah
they're all kind of like super uh
reliable for the you know
they're they're like if we have a show
where they're not in much of the show
it's a concern of okay let's make sure
that they're covered in some way you
know does anyone come to michael czech
say listen
michael you're wise
you know what
wait a second nobody ever uttered that
sentence nobody
nobody comes to you
and says you know hey i'm thinking about
leaving what do you think no we everyone
talks but you talk about like i said
it's like working in the police
department everybody's like i gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here like
everyone it's like a prison yard
everyone's saying they want to leave
right and then but yet they can't like
it's it's hard to do i i don't believe
it until
are you jealous credits change are you
jealous of them leaving part of me gets
jealous of them leaving but part of me
would be jealous if i left and they
stayed you know like right you do you
will miss it it is sure it is it's so
much of it it literally raises you as a
comic kind of in the way clubs do so
it's hard to
walk away completely but
you know i'm sure the first week we're
doing a show and we're stressed out over
something i would be like i should have
just [ __ ] left you know immediately
that's all you that's all you can think
about but they're they're all they've
been there for 10 years like how you
know they
they kind of they kind of had their fill
i guess